we already have excuses from Donald
Trump about apparently not paying taxes
quote that makes me smart and the
amazing quote I know our complex tax
laws better than anyone thus quote I am
the only one who can fix them
nevertheless we begin day five of our
wait for Donald Trump to come up with an
excuse for why he accused a woman who
was not in a sex tape of being in a sex
tape when he himself was in a playboy
tape spraying champagne with premature
jocularity please note how remarkable it
is that Trump has not blamed his agent
for that or a celebrity look-alike
service or claimed he didn't know that
playboy made sex tapes were simply
insisted that the Second Amendment
protects his right to bear arms and legs
and and the rest because Trump has an
excuse for everything
the top 50 of them I mean recently his
excuse for not releasing his taxes quote
I'm being audited so I can't but he will
quote when she releases her 33,000
emails but quote I don't think anybody
cares but quote there's nothing to learn
from them plus his tax rate is quote
none of your business his excuse for his
bad poll numbers the quote Google search
engine was suppressing the bad news
about Hillary Clinton
without the quote disgusting and corrupt
media he'd be leading by 20 percent and
he's not losing anyway quote I certainly
don't think it is appropriate to start
changing all of a sudden when you have
been winning Trump's excuses about
Russia reportedly hacking into
Democratic National Committee computers
quote it could be Russia but it could
also be China could also be lots of
other people it also could be somebody
sitting on the bed that weighs 400
pounds okay
shooting down malaysian airlines flight
mh17 quote they say it wasn't them going
on a Larry King TV show carried by
Russian state-sponsored television and
saying that he doubted Vladimir Putin
was attempting to influence the u.s.
elections he thought it was for a Larry
King podcast his excuses for supporting
in September 2002 the invasion of Iraq a
2004
interview proves he didn't he told Sean
Hannity he didn't when Howard Stern
asked him he said quote I don't know
even though the tape shows he actually
said quote yeah I guess so
quote by the time the war started I was
against it
quote shortly thereafter I was really
against it and regardless when he said
it whatever he said he quote was not a
politician his excuse for his
performance in the first debate quote
they also gave me a defective mic but he
was not sniffing because also quote the
mic was very bad but maybe it was good
enough to hear breathing his excuse for
not attacking the clintons marriage
during the debate I really eased up
because I didn't want to hurt anyone's
feelings then he attacked the marriage
anyway
then he questioned if Hillary had been
loyal to bill also moderator Lester Holt
quote Lester as a Democrat it's a phony
system they're all Democrats no for the
record Holt is a registered Republican
Trump then said he quote did a great job
no he deserved to quote cc+ but quote
I'm not complaining no Lester Holt
rigged the debate quote what a rigged
deal I tell you we're in such a rigged
system Trump's excuse if he loses the
election quote I'm afraid the election
is going to be rigged his opponent
cleared by investigators it's a quote
rigged system but quote it's not just
the political system that's rigged it's
the whole economy yet not everything is
rigged
Trump's excuse when he asked Russia to
hack Clinton's email quote of course I'm
being sarcastic
Trump's excuse when he called President
Obama the co-founder of Isis quote they
don't get sarcasm small crowd size in
Colorado Springs the fire marshal was a
Democrat small crowd size in Washington
DC six hundred thousand people would
have been there but quote they don't
allow them to come in how his wife
Melania got into the country despite
possible immigration irregularities
she'll hold a news conference why his
wife Melania has not held a news
conference they released a letter from
her lawyer his excuse for claiming that
global warming was a hoax perpetrated by
the Chinese quote I do not say it he
tweeted it his excuse quote I often
joked that this is done for the benefit
of China obviously I joke but this is
done for the benefit of
Trump's excuse for his connection to all
right white supremacist Hillary Clinton
quote came up with the term the reported
excuse for violence at his rallies
it adds quote excitement his excuse for
not disavowing white supremacist David
Duke during a TV interview quote a very
bad earpiece is excused for proposing a
Muslim ban quote it was just a
suggestion his excuse for saying you
could shoot people on Fifth Avenue in
New York City and not lose any support
quote obviously it was a joke his excuse
for calling Ted Cruz a quote [ __ ] quote
we were all just having fun his excuse
for disparaging Heidi Cruz's appearance
quote I didn't start it his GOP debate
excuse for disparaging remarks towards
women oftentimes it's fun it's kidding
we have a good time his excuse for
commenting that if she weren't his
daughter he might be dating his daughter
quote cute it was cute his excuse for
abusive remarks about former Miss
Universe alicia machado quote she gained
a massive amount of weight his excuse
for disparaging machado after she
endorsed Hillary Clinton quote checkout
sex tank his excuse for the three to
five a.m. overnight tweet storm that
included the phrase check out sex tape
quote at least you know I will be there
awake to answer the call and lastly his
excuse for making all his harsh remarks
I do regret it particularly where it may
have caused personal pain okay
that was August 19th that was before the
Washington hotel birth through news
conference before he talked about
disarming Hillary couldn't a Secret
Service detail before he physically
mocked Hillary Clinton's pneumonia
collapsed for the raise your hand if
you're a non-christian thing before he
said he might not recognize the outcome
of the election for a slam the entire
african-american community maker
Brzezinski marine doubt ex-cia director
gates Colin Kapernick Obama's poll
numbers compared to Putin's Alicia
Machado
the Federal Reserve System Jeff Zucker
Elizabeth Warren and Rosie O'Donnell
again that's the closure I'm Keith
Olbermann watch this space